we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail caller is asking about whether
i'm gonna be campaigning for any twenty
twenty Democratic candidates let's
listen to the voicemail and there's
actually a bigger discussion here that
I've been wanting to have with you take
a listen hey David
this is your this is Davis from
California I just want to know are you
gonna get on any campaign trail are you
gonna back any candidate he's seem to
have a lot of information good
information and you seem to explain
yourself well I think maybe you could be
an asset so I hope you find a candidate
you believe in and then explain to us
why you believe in it I'd like to hear
your opinion I mean there's some good
ones out there and I think there's some
good ones that aren't going to make the
cut based on their age experience or
just not the right time okay dope buy
yeah so listen I've made clear I'm going
to eventually tell you who I support in
the 2020 Democratic primary I it's an
open question I'm not gonna be out on
the campaign trail let me put it that
way I'm doing my show and I want to even
if it's known who I'm supporting I want
to be doing credible analysis of of the
campaign and of the race so I don't see
myself campaigning for anybody
although circumstances could change who
knows I don't know whether it makes
sense for me to particularly early on
say who I'm going to be supporting and I
genuinely don't know who that is at this
point in time I mean I've made clear I
like Bernie I supported him in 2016 I
like Elizabeth Warren Andrew yang has
some interesting ideas although I think
within a week within ten days we may
know whether or not he's going to have
any chance whatsoever at this thing
because if he doesn't get to like three
or four percent in the polling after
next week's presidential debate I think
he's basically done and in fact he won't
be allowed in the next set of debates
unless he gets to I think it's three or
four percent in the national polls I
don't know what the audience wants me to
do on this I again I'm going to tell you
ultimately who I'm voting for in the
and there is almost total certainty that
in the general election I will vote for
the Democratic nominee I'm not going to
vote for Trump it's conceivable that
something could happen we're in
Massachusetts where it's effectively a
guarantee that the Democrat will win
would I support a third party candidate
maybe and I'll be totally transparent
with you but I don't know that there is
much to be gained from me at this point
you know I see channels where people are
there jumping on the yang Yang or their
Bernie or Buster's or they're saying I'm
with Liz or they're saying a Tulsi
Gabbard is the only serious candidate
and I'm supporting her I don't know what
that would do in terms of the audience's
relationship to the show and and I don't
yet know who I am supporting but I think
there is a discussion to be had about
should I as soon as I decide who I'm
supporting become a campaigner for that
person on the show in the context of the
primary or should I just wait until
Massachusetts votes in whenever it is
March of 2020 I guess it is and at that
point say who I'm voting for I don't
know my goal is we need to remove Donald
Trump and whatever role I can play in
making that more likely that's the role
I want to play so I want to hear from
you about this what what to what degree
should I be actively cheerleading for a
particular candidate in the Democratic
primary I've already said who I like
best and it's the two people I consider
to be the most progressive Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and I would
gladly vote for either in the eventual
general election let me know what you
think and maybe we'll follow up about
this on the bonus show which by the way
you should become a member right now so
you can access the bonus show sign up in
under a minute
@ww join pakman.com